[Música]
vai fazer dois anos e setembro que teve
início o projeto desenvolvimento
companhias rede de coordenação
pedagógica é novo
esta iniciativa promovida pelo direitor
de nova antónio rendas e coordenado pela
pró vitória patrícia rosado pinto tem
como objetivo sensibilizar os docentes
da nova para os temas relacionados com o
ensino deste projeto surgiram já três
grupos de trabalho primeiro procurou
fazer um estudo sobre as tarefas de
coordenação pedagógica é nova o segundo
gol incentivou os estudantes a
apresentar em museus de ensino novos e
grupo do qual não faz parte escolheu o
tema um valor do ensino
eu trabalho no nosso grupo que hoje é
que vem falar quem é que acha que o
ensino em particular o ensino
universitário é muito importante
no entanto o alto valor do ensino do
vídeo que eu tenho é que embora todos
tenhamos a noção conhecida é muito
importante não é fácil
o valor do ensino curiosamente se a
pergunta for igual valor
são provavelmente as respostas são mais
consensuais é que não há como por
exemplo o número de projetos é muito
fácil saber as verbas atribuídas a um
desses projetos é possível saber o
número de público e receber por exemplo
através do fator de impacto público e é
cada vez mais fácil e fiável saber o
número de citações que cada um desses
artigos têm como estes dados objetivos e
usando uma forma que achar mais adequada
é muito fácil chegar a um número e este
número e chegar em 10 que nós no meio
acadêmico no momento consideramos como
sempre um valor na investigação
convenci num é tudo um pouco mais
complexo é que o ensino implica sempre
dos partos são entendendo tem vontade
própria e muitas vezes até o objetivo de
frente
o valor do ensino depende também da
melhor ou pior opção entre essas partes
nem tampouco desafiados a pensarem no
que é o valor do ensino e provavelmente
alguns tenham pensado nas verbas que
devem ser investidos no município o que
o valor do ensino está na excelência dos
professores que são talvez lembrado do
tipo e qualidade de aulas que são
lecionadas voltei da forma como os
alunos são avaliados e quem sabe se
alguém não será também lembrá-lo dos
diferentes modelos para medir a
qualidade do ensino
no entanto todos estes aspectos são
instrumentos ou métodos de implementação
do ensino nada disto é o valor do ensino
agora estou 100 certo sim no início do
nosso trabalho não chegamos exatamente
como estão a sentir agora
mas rapidamente percebi a música que
dentro do grupo não conseguimos obter
respostas
então decidimos fazer entrevistas e como
a esmagadora maioria das pessoas passa
pelo ensino universitário está na
indústria no nas empresas enfim está na
sociedade está a oposição academy ano
teremos três setores da sociedade
a indústria pesada e fomos entrevistar
uma pessoa de cada uma dessas áreas e
por isso falamos com joão paulo oliveira
da mina viga e campinense joão passos no
hospital cuf infante santo hino tem por
menos da orquestra metropolitana de
lisboa
mas tínhamos que eu vi também isso a
academia e como os elementos do nosso
grupo pertencem e três unidades
orgânicas da nova
achamos que seria muito interessante
entre estados diretores dessas
unidades orgânicas efetivamente foi isso
que conseguimos não foi fácil mas
conseguimos e por isso entrevistamos os
diretores daniel traça francês que mel
em fernando santana deixando contatos
entretanto uma história que eu acho
interessante né empresa do norte todos
os seguimentos artesanais é que há uns
tempos teve problema
quando estou ao seu sistema de pagamento
automático começou tem muitas
informações por parte dos clientes
porque de pacotes pura e simplesmente
não tenham seu imenso talento
isso é um problema grave e tem que ser
resolvido mesma altura o dono da empresa
não tenha ninguém com um formação e
tempo para encontrar uma solução muito
que os lembrou e conta com um soro
enfrentar o que já há algum tempo vinha
desafiando porque ela já se tema de tese
de mestrado
o pessoal ficou entusiasmada disse que
arranjou do estudante de mestrado para
fazer é tentar arranjar uma solução
estudantes tiveram trabalhos lenta em
cinco meses minou as suas teses livros e
teve algumas boas notas e arranjar uma
solução mesmo que os fizeram sentir na
zona de policiamento baixo do tapete
rolante que traz as caixas com os
segmentos colocar uma balança estava
ligada ao sistema computorizado quando
um pacote num peso e fiel estava
estudando se num lava e um braço com
quem como via caixa do pt
a caixa desde agora é e depois eu
voltava ao seu curso normal
o sistema dos alunos foi montado um dois
três meses 10 formações por parte dos
planos sucesso absurdo
no entanto quando um diretor da empresa
estava consultar o seu relatório
trimestral verificou que afinal estava
desligada a 2 mesmo show que está em e
foi ver o que se passava chamou
responsável uma linha de comportamento
salvar aquilo é que era um martírio é
twingo estava sendo preparada
travamos o trabalho nos ainda montando
aquilo mesmo depois de desligados
assistindo sobre o problema da nossa
idéia é que ganhamos aqui entre nós
observamos a volta compramos uma
ventoinha deixa também o cargo junto ao
pt quando em uma caixa de lixo
estamos a contar esta história porque
demonstra dois pontos muito importantes
porque foram assinado entre minhas
entrevistas
o primeiro tem a ver com a forma como os
dias os problemas ou em termos mais
gerais dos desafios são enfrentados pela
carne e pela sociedade a sociedade aqui
representada pelo dom da empresa tem que
arranjar uma solução tem que ser
pragmático
se não tem os meios ao seu alcance para
fazer a actuação dos juízes têm o seu
turno a academia academia
os instrumentos da escrita no
conhecimento e às vezes como foi o caso
a terra sofre problemas está relacionado
com as encontradas
não há dúvida nenhuma que anda essas
funções resolve o problema mas monson
que o ovo comunicação entre a sociedade
os funcionários da empresa que possui os
alunos na academia é que se deve essa
comunicação tivesse havido esse de algo
que tivesse havido ao fim ao cabo
comunicação o conjugação de diferentes
chover provavelmente sem chegar a uma
terceira solução quem sabe se os três
responderão à pergunta fundamental que é
porque é que a coty pura e simplesmente
não tem sabonete novembro
é por isso que a sociedade aqui mais do
ponto de vista do mundo empresarial
considera que o ensino universitário
deve ter uma relação mais estreita com
as empresas
ficamos a saber que isso já acontece há
alguns passos a serem dados disse que
nomeadamente é que nessa nova onde
existem os pilotos e os pitons programas
de estágio 5 que os alunos realizam
empresas e que ocorre entre os dois
times no entanto a academia continua
a relação entre o ensino universitário
ea investigação muito ponto também foi
mencionada que não é frio aqui na
história que contei está relacionado com
formação integral
o ensino não deve não só preocupações
ensino universitário deve não só
preocupar se com a transmissão do cheiro
que tem 15 técnicos mas deve também ter
preocupação entre os alunos princípios
de ética e determinada e nesta
perspectiva do ensino integral lá não
podemos deixar de mencionar o modelo
pedagógico que é praticado na nova s b
que dá pelo nome casp e cá explicou fim
ao cabo e o acrônimo em pó seis pilares
deste museu opção nuland
a atitude também fundamental está
relacionado ao mundo o maiô onde está
inserida a cidade
neste âmbito a um projeto muito
interessante o projeto e lisboa onde o
trabalho dos alunos e dos investigadores
está serve de base a lisboa extremamente
original estático nível de plataformas
de ar que sua mente suas treinamento
interessantes como por parte da
sociedade valorizar o ensino numa das
nossas múltiplas reuniões para conseguir
tirar uma conclusão à altura
mas lembro de um episódio pessoal comigo
quando eu ainda estava no no primeiro
andar foi colado à final do primeiro
semestre
estávamos a pedir exames estava em casa
a estudar é uma sexta feira 13 com a
tarde estava em casa estava cansado só
de fazer uma pausa e passá-la ascende a
provisão senta no sofá
hoje em dia não seria nada estranha
futebol a qualquer dia a qualquer hora
mas naquela altura a atenção estamos a
falar de 1989
nessa altura além de só duas ou três
pessoas em portugal têm computador em
casa e ninguém sequer tinha o telemóvel
nem assalto em portugal tudo os jogos
começarão às três da tarde e jogávamos
todos ao domingo
isso que não querem estar ainda mais em
uma equipe que estava vestida por coisas
foi só no final e tudo jogadores tinham
me dado um dos oito anos vai pintar na
altura claro que eles têm fica então
ainda mais curioso se teme tanto nos fan
e fiquei a ver aqui o lançamento da
trama acabar bennett mas quando nós
chegamos em pagar em direito e tenta
fintar o adversário ficando com o nome
do pai mas ao roma também entra na
grande área e gol foi go go go 3 de
março de 1989 portugal pela primeira vez
era campeão do mundo de futebol em sub
mal sabia eu que a vitória daquela
seleção comandada por isso desconhecido
licenciado em educação física é e mestre
em metros do treino e desporto era um
sinal de que o futebol em portugal e
nunca mais seria o mesmo
dois anos mais tarde eu e os meus
colegas pontos e mais 120 mil pessoas
estávamos no antigo estádio da luz
carvalho estava pelas costuras para
testemunhar a conquista
muito campeonato do mundo de futebol
agora na categoria the sun vive
novamente comandado por carlos queiroz
mas não pensa em que os sucessos são
casos em suave e não são muito menos são
muito menos fruto do acaso
já há muito que a sociedade clamava por
um futebol mais competitivo já que nem
ouviu e cpu e criou o ensino da
influência que ao longo de décadas tem
vindo a formar treinadores que não só
têm vindo a mudar o futebol a nível
nacional com tem vindo a mudar o futebol
a nível mundial
isto é o volume sujeito à detenção
cuidado
se houver coerência de ensino ou c
o ensino foi desajustado da realidade
os deputados podem ser dramáticos podem
até ter pôr em causa a nossa integridade
física e podem chegar a pôr em risco
podem chegar é podem podem tornar num
inferno momentos mais teve ice do nosso
dna
por isso eu eu em um mina do nosso grupo
e todos um desafio que o valor do
incêndio
proponho a todos um desafio que o valor
do ensino que hoje estamos a criar
prevista a tenha ultrapassar com sucesso
o momento é difícil mas também desfrutar
de movimentos da vida
o ensino por si só não garante uma
sociedade melhor né
as sociedades ensino jamais evoluir a
qual será então o hiv índex do ensino
[Aplausos]